في اخبارنا الاخرى قال مفوض السياسات
الخارجيه في الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل
قلينا الوضع في اوكرانيا مقلق وان عدد
الجنود الروس حاليا ضعف ما كان عليه قبل
الحرب وشدد برال في افاده امام البرلمان
الاوروبي في على اهميه الاستمرار في تقديم
دعم لاوكرانيا
اوكرانيا نريد لاوكرانيا ان تربح الحرب
لكن الواقع على الارض مقلق في الوقت
الراهن عدد الجنود الروس هناك ضعف ما كان
عليه قبل الحرب وقد بدات تجهيز للهجوم
الروسي المضاد حتى لو كان على نطاق صغير
ولاول مره لا تتمتع اوكرانيا باسبقيه من
خلال وجود مزيد من القوات على الارض لدى
اوكرانيا نداء للدول الاعضاء في الاتحاد
الاوروبي وجميع اولئك الذين يساعدونها
لتقديم دعم اكبر وقد التقينا في مجموعه
رمشتاين لتنسيق المساعدات العسكريه
لاوكرانيا من اجل تقييم الوضع ولمعرفه ما
اذا كنا بحاجه الى مزيد من الذخيره والت
للقوات الاوكرانيه من اجل الاستمرار في
مسانده كييف
من جهته قال رئيس الاوكراني انه تم تاكيد
في اجتماع وزراء دفاع حلف الناتو
امس على ارسال مزيد منظمه الدفاع الجوي
والدبابات والمدفعيه لبلاده وشدد زيلنسكي
في خطابه اليومي على ضروره الاسراع باتخاذ
القرارات وتنفيذها
تم تاكيده ارسال المزيد من انظمه الدفاع
الجوي من قبل الشركاء ومزيد من الدبابات
والمدفعيه والقذائف ومزيد من عمليات
التدريب لجيشنا لا يمكن الابلاغ عن كل شيء
بشان رمشتاين علنا يجب ترك جزء كبير من
الاتفاقات خلف الابواب المغلقه لكن يمكنني
القول بثقه من الوجهه الاساسيه لم تتغير
تبذل اوكرانيا وشركائها معا قصار جهدهم
لضمان خساره الدوله الارهابيه نرى الان ان
الكرملين يحاول زياده كل عدوان محتمل انهم
في عجله من امرهم لذلك السرعه مهمه جدا في
كل شيء في اتخاذ القرارات وتنفيذها السرعه
تنقذ حياه الناس
من ناحيته قال وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
اوكسي
المباحثات بشان توليد الطائرات لاوكرانيا
ما زالت مستمره بشان نوعيه الطائرات التي
يمكن الحصول عليها
تم الاعلان عن المواعيد النهائيه لتوليد
المعدات ايصالها الى اوكرانيا يرتبط بشكل
اساسي بمده التدريب اما بالنسبه لتوليد
الطائرات فالمباحثات ما زالت جاريه وسيبقى
تحديد نوعيه الطائرات التي يمكن ان نحصل
عليها في وقت لاحق نظمنا منذ فتره طويله
توليد الذخيره من دول النيتو كمساعده
عسكريه وتقنيه وابرمنا عقودا للعام الجاري
لضمان الامداد المنتظم سيزداد هذا الدعم
حتى نغلق الاجواء فوق العديد من المدن
تدريجيا الرادارات ستصلنا خلال الربيع
وعندها سنكون قادرين على فهم تدمير
الطائرات المسيره الايرانيه وصواريخ العدو
او الصواريخ الباليستيه